un derramamiento de sangre fue evitado
así lo aseguro el presidente ruso
Vladimir Putin en agradecimiento al
grupo Wagner por haber detenido su
rebelión del pasado 24 de junio que iba
en contra de Moscú además aseguró que
mantiene sus promesas de no enjuiciarlos
no obstante aprovecho para arremeter en
contra de la fallida marcha
los organizadores de la rebelión
traicionaron a su país a su pueblo fue
precisamente este resultado criminal el
que querían los enemigos de Rusia tanto
los neonazis en kiev como susamos
occidentales y todo tipo de traidores
nacionales querían que los soldados
rusos se mataran unos a otros horas
antes fue revelado un audio de 11
minutos en el que el jefe de grupo de
mercenarios Wagner dijo que la rebelión
no fue un intento para derrocar al
gobierno de Rusia sino para darle una
lección y preservar la existencia del
grupo ya que se planeaba acabar con
Wagner a partir del primero de julio el
jefe de la milicia privada dijo que sus
tropas lograron acercarse a 200
kilómetros de mos cú antes de decidir
dar la vuelta y regresar hemos
demostrado una clase magistral Como
debería haber sido el 24 de febrero de
2022 no teníamos el objetivo de derrocar
al régimen existente y al poder
legítimamente electo como se ha
mencionado muchas veces antes hemos dado
la vuelta para no derramar la sangre de
los soldados rusos
Se desconoce desde donde pregollón grabó
su mensaje así como cuando además sus
afirmaciones no pueden ser verificadas
aunque supuestamente se llegó a un
acuerdo que haría que prigollín se
trasladará a belarus aunque no se ha
podido confirmar si realmente llegó al
país o no O cuál será su estado
medios estatales rusos dicen que todo
sigue igual en varios centros de
concentración de Wagner
pero el futuro
paramilitar dentro y fuera de Ucrania
sigue siendo incierto